رمضان قديروف ان مسلحي القوات
الشيشانية سيطروا على معظم مدينة
كوناشينكوف يعلن سقوط مائتين
وثلاثين قتيلا في صفوف القوات
وموسكو ترفض ودول اوروبية تبحث
عن ملاجئ تقيها من النووية
ومجنون كوريا يجري تجربة لنوويه.
فهل تندلع الحرب العالمية بعد كل
الالمانية برلين انها ابطلت عبوة
ناسفة في مجمع يضم وكالة صحفية
باوكرانيا تضمنت قيامها بتدمير
مسيرة تابعة للجيش الاوكراني.
اسلحة المانية الى اوكرانيا تثير
انتقادات حادة على شولتس اعلن
الروسية مشاهد لعمل انظمة
الصواريخ والمدافع ذاتية الدفع
نظرا لتراجع المناعة من اللقاح
وتخفيف القيود وترى الادارة
مائة وخمسين مليون دولار لقتال
اوكرانيا لصد الغزو الروسي.
روسية واضافت انها تفتح تحقيقا
في الواقعة. الرئيس الاوكراني
بينما حذر من ان التمويل على وشك
النفاذ وحث الكونجرس على تفويض
الامريكية اصابة مائة مليون شخص
خلال الخريف والشتاء المقبلين
الاوكرانية في معارك اوديسا. من
ناحية اخرى قالت شرطة العاصمة
الامريكية ان بلادهم غير مستعدة
تماما لذلك العدد الكبير من
قواته في اوروبا هل هي الحرب يا
سادة? الاحداث شبح كورونا لا
يعملون بشكل وثيق مع في الناتو
ساعين الى ردع الخصم الروسي ليرد
رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي بدعوته
الى ادراج الولايات المتحدة في
يغيب. فبعد عودته في مدينة
شنغهاي الصينية وتسجيله موجة
المشاركة المباشرة في الحرب. اما
وراء اعلان البنتاجون عن تعداد
تصعيد خطير. البنتاجون يكشف عن
حشد مائة الف جندي امريكي.
خامسة في احدى عشرة دولة افريقية
قد تشهد الولايات المتحدة
اوكرانيا قائلا ان الدور
الامريكي يرقى الى مستوى
قائمة مجرمي الحرب وحملها
مسؤولية الجرائم المرتكبة في
البديلة. روسيا بدأت بتجهيز بنية
تحتية جديدة لتصدير الغاز وتكافح
المنتظر خطة امريكية لازاحة
ايران عن حليفتها روسيا? الخطة
غازها عن اوروبا ايضا قبل ان
تمتنع اوروبا اصلا عن شرائه?
اكثر من ثلاثمائة مدني تم
انقاذهم في المرحلة الاولى من
عملية الاجلاء من مجمع ازوفستال
بماريبول. تضع الشروط هذه المرة
بوباسنا شرقي اوكرانيا. الناطق
باسم وزارة الدفاع الروسية ايجور
وخمسة عشر. وقال مسؤول السياسة
الخارجية جوزي بوريل ان
لتايوان. محاولة اخيرة. قالت
تقارير غربية ان منسق المحادثات
العالمية التانية. وسيقام خلال
الاحتفال بهذه المناسبة مناورة
عازمة على اتخاذ هذه الخطوة. فهل
تكون عازمة على قطع امدادات
روسيا لنقل الصادرات التي اعتادت
اوروبا شراءها سنوات. لكن موسكو
الروابط. سيستغرق بناء البنية
التحتية الجديدة التي تحتاجها
النووية الايرانية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي اندريكي مورا سيزور
ثماني عشرة مقاتلة صينية اخترقت
اجواءها من الجنوب الغربي. وقالت
التواطؤ مع القوات الاجنبية
باشارة الى الدعم الامريكي
القيامة. مصطلح تردد كثيرا في
الايام الاخيرة ويستخدمه بوتين
اقبال الشباب على تقليد العادات
الغربية. صحيفة ذا الصن
البريطانية قالت انه في حال
القبض على شباب بالجنز الضيق تتم
المزيد. يحذر من احتمال نشوب حرب
عالمية ثالثة. نشرت الدفاع
المضادة للطائرات فانت سير اس
وان خلال العمل العسكرية
الاصابة اعلن الرئيس جو بايدن عن
حزمة اسلحة امريكية جديدة بقيمة
ايضا استعراضا لطائرة القيادة
الثمانين المعروفة بيوم القيامة.
كثيرا بهذه الطائرة في الوقت
الحالي. هل هو على علم باندلاع
مصيرهم معروفا لدى الجميع واظنه
لن يلبس بقية حياته وماذا بعد يا
ارتداء بناطيل الجينز الضيقة.
قرار كيم جاء خشية من زيادة
وستكون السابعة. فالى اين يصبو
كيم جونغ هذه الاسلحة. قوانين
تكون جاهزة لاجراء تجربة هناك
بحلول هذا الشهر على ابعد تقدير.
المفاوضين لن يمنح ايران انذارا
اخر. فهل يكون هذا القرار
الارهاب حيث ان الاتحاد يسعى
لكسر الجمود انقاذ اتفاق الفين
بعدم القيام بذلك مجددا ثم يطلق
سراحهم واذا تم تكرارها فسيكون
معاقبتهم بتصوير لحظة ارتداء
بنطال واجبارهم على كتابة تعهد
موسكو للعثور على مشترين جدد
للسلع الاساسية حيث تقطع
سابقة هذا القبيل بانها وسيلة
للدفاع عن سيادة البلاد ومواجهة
والتي ستحمل القيادة وكبار
الضباط في حال نشوب حرب نووية.
الشمالي كيم جونج اون ينشئ شرطة
ازياء تنزل الى الشارع لمنع
كيم الغريبة. بعد زيادة ارتدائها
من قبل شعبه الزعيم الكوري
الطائرات التي دخلت منطقة الدفاع
الجوي بينما وصفت بكين مهاما
طهران حاليا وقد يساعد في رفع
الحرس الثوري الايراني من لائحة
وزارة الدفاع التايوانية ان سلاح
الجو سارع اليوم الى تحذير
حرب عالمية بسبب الازمة الحالية؟
الصين لا تتوقف. اعلنت تايوان ان
استعراضية لطائرات مقاتلة اسرع
من الصوت. وستتضمن المناورات
في الذكرى السابعة والسبعين.
روسيا على النازية في الحرب
وهي مصممة لتكون مركز التحكم
للرأي الروسي. فلماذا يلوح بوتين
كوريا الديموقراطية الشعبية تعد
موقع اختبار بونجاي ار اي. وقد
الشمالية اطلقت صاروخا بالستيا
من غواصة في الوقت الذي تعهدت
يخطط لضرب احد اعدائه? وهناك
خرجت تحذيرات غربية من تجربة
الفين وسبعة عشر. فما الذي يريده
المجنون من هذه التجارب? وهل
الباليستية العابرة للقارات هذا
العام للمرة الاولى منذ عام
وبعد شهرين من القتال الدامي
اوكرانيا يخشى الاوروبيون وحتى
نووية جديدة لكوريا الشمالية حين
قالت نائبة المتحدث باسم وزارة
لاوكرانيا بات سكان اربع دول
غربية يسعون بشكل متزايد للحصول
يتنازل احد الطرفين؟ البحث عن
ملاجئ من النووي. مع تلميحات
روسيا المتكررة للغرب بشن هجوم
نووي اذا ما تدخل اكثر في غزوها
بعض الامريكيين من ان يستهدف
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
على معلومات حول بناء وكذلك شراء
ملاجئ واقية من الاشعة النووية.
كيم جونغ هل من قوانين غريبة
اخرى? الطائرة المرعبة. يوم
الخارجية الامريكية تقدر
الولايات المتحدة ان جمهورية
فيه بيونغيانغ بتطوير قواتها
النووية. وكثفت كوريا الشمالية
في الاونة الاخيرة تجارب الاسلحة
كما تعهدت بيونج يانج بتطوير
الاوكرانيسكي يطرح شروطه الى
طاولة المفاوضات. استعادة كييف
كامل السيطرة على اراضيها عودة
اكثر من خمسة ملايين لاجئ
الاوروبي اشترط زلنسكي ايضا
معاقبة الضباط الروس على اعمالهم
في اوكرانيا بينما ترد موسكو ان
اقليم الدنبس وشبه جزيرة القرم
قواتها النووية باسرع وتيرة
ممكنة مع استئناف تجارب الصواريخ
صاروخا بالستيا من غواصة حيث اكد
الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان كوريا
وجه اعدائه? جنون كيم. وسط رعب
نووي. كوريا الشمالية تطلق
مرة اخرى بكابوس جديد ولكن هذه
المرة من غواصته النووية بوسط
البحر. طائرة يوم القيامة مجددا
لارعاب اعداء روسيا والصين تخترق
قريبا دولا اخرى باسلحة فتاكة
فهل يشهر بوتين سلاحه النووي في
اوكراني الى مدنهم وقراهم. حصول
بلاده على عضوية الاتحاد
المرصودة لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح. شروط اوكرانيا. الرئيس
القادمة من كورونا في امريكا
وبايدن يحذر من نفاذ المبالغ
روسيا وموسكو تحضر لرد مناسب مئة
مليون اصابة متوقعة خلال الموجة
امداد خطوط جديدة لغازها. فهل
تقطعه عن اوروبا تماما? الولايات
مقترح اوروبي لرفع مشروط للحرس
الثوري من قائمة الارهاب. فهل هي
زالا نسكي. هذه شروطنا كي نتحاور
مع الروس. بينما موسكو لا تعيره
اي اهتمام وتستمر في حربها. في
حين يبحث الغرب عن ملاجئ تقيهم
خارجة عن اي تفاوض. فهل تبقى هذه
المفاوضات بعد تلك الشروط؟ وهل
محاولة لابعاد ايران عن التحالف
مع روسيا? بينما تبحث روسيا عن
المتحدة تحشد قواتها في اوروبا
وتؤكد ان العقوبات لم تؤثر على
اجواء تايوان مجددا بطائراتها.
فهل يعد هذا اشارة لاجتياحها?
من الاسلحة النووية. فهل الحرب
النووية حقا? المجنون يقلق الغرب
هذا?